cerium is one of only two elements which
if you strike it will make sparks one of
them is iron and the other one is cerium
and so I bought this when I was on
holiday a year ago and I haven't had a
chance to use it it contains a it
consists of a rod here which has claims
to have several metals including cerium
let's see if it sparks
okay so Syria Melbourne number 58 has
some bizarre uses would you believe it's
used in self-cleaning ovens so it's not
very easy to do but once you get the
hang of it it does go quite well cerium
also has uses such as for staining glass
so if you want to stay in your glass
yellow then you can use cerium in that
what is happening is that tiny pieces of
cerium are being knocked off and in the
air they just burst into flames so I
think the property is not so much that
it forms a spark but that you can knock
off the right size lumps to make them
burn these things that are being knocked
off are probably just a few nanometers
that's a thousand millionth of a meter
across so they're very tiny size and the
surface area is high because it's small
so it has a large surface compared to
its volume and so it reacts with oxygen
very rapidly and heats up and bursts
into flame the point about cerium is
that very small particles of cerium
oxide are now becoming quite important
in various areas of Technology there's a
company or several companies that are
using nanoparticles of cerium oxide as
an additive for fuels to make particular
diesel fuel to try and make it burn
better and give more power when you are
driving diesel cars
and here in Nottingham we're trying to
develop new ways of making these
nanoparticles by reacting cerium with
high temperature water and it's been
quite successful it's also used in
organic synthesis by chemists for making
organic molecules because it can be very
reactive in certain circumstances cerium
is also used in permanent magnets for
obvious applications in magnetism